[Music]
i would like to thank you for your
recent reputation
of what was that woman called han
yeah if you guys haven't watched it guys
please go there i think it was the best
reputation
down in history uh it was it was
absolutely epic
with new words but today it's something
a bit different there's a bit of a
controversial topic that's been
happening um now we've been discussing
how we can tackle this i'm going to come
from different
um venues should i say jungles angles
yes so hijab are you ready let's get
straight into it because i think we
waste a lot of time you know talking
sometimes unnecessarily no problem yeah
okay let's get straight into it yeah so
this was a baby
baby bbc interview yeah woman's hour
yeah
isn't it ironic woman's hour but look
what she does to a sister a muslim woman
how many uh female imams are there
um in the uk at the moment just because
i presume we
will get to this more but representing
of course women
uh which he will do as part of this how
many do we have in britain
i mean i think let's give quick context
this is the reason um
she's um the the lead not leader man
of the muslim council of britain yeah is
it she's the new
if i'm not mistaken yeah she's she's the
head like she's the
director now with the muslim council of
britain yeah okay yeah so
just imagine you have just been like
awarded something yeah you're a champion
yeah imagine
yeah you've done something and this is
how you've been treated
again i'm not i don't have a clue on
these numbers because my role is making
sure that
we include our affiliates particularly
women in the work that we are doing and
making sure that
um where our structures as well as the
work we do
and are truly representative so i think
that you know do we sorry
you don't know that's fine if you don't
know but do do we have female imams in
this country
i mean again it's not are you referring
to
chaplains are you referring to women
that lead the prayer what are you
referring to and i think
you tell me i i'm genuinely intrigued to
know of course uh female priests have
been around for some time
uh we've also seen the the advent of
female rabbis in this country
what is the picture for women leading
prayer in britain
in in muslim communities well i think
my role isn't really to um adjudicate or
to to examine that part of spirituality
i think
where women want to make those choices
and where you know
that these are all religious discussions
oh no no of course
it was just i thought because the muslim
council of britain's played such an
important role
in getting the number of muslims for
instance added to the census i mean that
was done at the turn of
of the turn of the century so we
actually knew how many muslims there
were
do we so do we have female imams i think
what's really important for the muslim
council in britain and the work that we
do is
actually that it's not about defining
you know or going into
the these types of questions regarding
spirituality but actually looking at
how we can benefit our communities
especially given the pandemic and given
of course the role that everybody needs
to be playing and we will get to
we will get to pandemic it's just quite
striking that you can't sort of answer
that question i recognize it's not a
religious or spiritual
role exactly i don't feel like that's
within the parameters
of my roles and responsibilities
especially as you know
the first elected female representative
how do you feel watching that you know
it's it's it's like you're having a you
know it was more like not interviewing
somebody was like having an interlocutor
and like like if i was speaking to an
atheist i would be hammering the
contingency argument over and over and
over and over again because i'm trying
to catch him
she's just you know become the chairman
chairwoman
of a muslim council yeah
and instead of congratulating asking
what she's planning on doing
well she was no mercy she was a no do
you know you don't know okay so there
isn't no
over and over six instances while
watching that
how do you feel i think there was many
fallacies that were committed in that
line of interrogation so the first thing
that i i think was fallacious
was the false equivalency uh between
imams and priests and rabbis
is false comparison because yeah so in
in christianity
you have ordinance that they go through
a kind of training program then they
become
either priests or whatever it is
depending on the dominant denomination
uh in judaism we have rabbis but those
individuals rabbis
and priests are usually trained they're
usually individuals who have
authority in the community so the
equivalent in a muslim community
especially in sunni islam would be
something like a mufti
potentially a sheikh and definitely
something like an islam or a
scholar so an imam is just someone who
leads the prayer
now you can have no authority like for
example in ramadan
um you have children leading the prayer
if if you have in a house
a mother and a child that's a male it's
very
possible that the the the boy leads the
mother in in
prayer even though she's much more
important in the hierarchy right
so this uh the reason why it's it's a
wrong question
in the first place or it's a false
equivalence is because you're comparing
apples and oranges
if you want to compare priests with a
group of
uh representatives from the muslim world
you should compare them with muftis et
cetera
having said that though yeah if we did
do that
i don't know about the comparison it's
actually quite an interesting question
definitely there are
female mufti's definitely there are
female aliens definitely they are
uh muslim but in terms of
proportion i don't know what i will say
is this before i forget
is that in the span of a thousand four
hundred years of islamic history
right there have been hundreds of
thousands of not just
scholars of islam that are female but
we're talking about prominent scholars
who have had
a lasting contribution and i'll just
give you one reference for that
dr muhammad has written a book his
voluminous
many different volumes on it's called
okay so it's just actually one subfield
called
hadith which is transmission and
teaching of hadith
and he catalogues in that ten thousand
women
ten thousand women in islamic history
okay now if you compare that like for
like
with ten thousand what women well
they're just women they're just exist
scholars scholars of just one tradition
one subfield which is hadith so
transmission of um
the prophetic tradition okay and in that
for example
some of the things i found were really
astonishing for example
because these are quite popular in the
jar of the seventh century not the one
the humbly that wrote
that another one uh
he had according to a tha in his uh
biography
400 female teachers now i want you to
imagine we're talking about the seventh
century
we're not we're not being tokenistic
here mentioning you know the sahaba yet
or the female scholars
that were there at the time of the
prophet we are talking about seventh
century
uh medieval uh arab world and this is a
place
a muslim world and a man had what does
it take for a man to have 400 female
educators it must mean that they're
being educated
and and they are given accessibility to
be able to educate
and this is one of many like thousands
of examples
the point the point is is that now is if
there isn't
a representation of female scholars now
today
in the uk or whatever it is is there a
problem i do think there's a problem i
think there's
something we need to do okay to try and
give more accessibility as was the case
by the way interestingly enough
at the time of a the prophet because he
he definitely
as is mentioned buhari he dedicated
times and places for educating women
specifically so that they don't
miss out and was the case with the fact
that you know the the habits were there
and was the case through islamic history
so i do think there's an issue
i think but the way that she's she's uh
handled that i think is completely wrong
it shows theological illiteracy she
doesn't know the differences between
priests
uh and one thing and so on one thing i
want to just touch upon before moving
into that area because there is like
the mistreatment uh of females
in today's time yes i'll go to that
i thought you would come from this angle
yeah maybe you missed it here but for
example
notice him about who are you to come and
tell us you're going to implement and
let's suppose there is no female imams
so what like like we need to come to
this angle because
we shouldn't be just because next
they're going to come and say to us why
is there no female prophets
yeah a good point so the thing is look
and this is where the sister was kind of
and i understand which is coming from i
can
you know we're in the tower sometimes we
try to you know
sugar down things we shouldn't there are
no female imams our religion doesn't
cover that and what
like the thing is and who are you to
come and tell me that i have to come to
your standards
which by the way is a false equivocation
because you're claiming
because there's no imams means there's
no scholars which you just debunked yeah
but we're saying
like to her world paradigm does she have
any right to come here and tell and
press a muslim woman who is a chairman
of the muslim council of britain
to come and tell her no but why why not
imams why not well she's the same woman
when it came to the issue of rabbis and
i don't know what
what did she say so emma barnett once
admitted she didn't believe in female
rabbis
yeah subhanallah look at hypocrisy yeah
rabbis go go speak to jewish lady and go
go question them that they don't even
have a right to divorce
and i know it's a different topic but
the thing is can you imagine you're just
pressing on the issue and who are you
and we need to have a backbone one like
there's something in the religion that
teaches allah said it
khalas i don't need to explain nothing
to you are you yes yes who are you
allah there's not imams there's look
there are no female imams doesn't
religion enough
to believe that no no not according to
99 one second
just because that is not allowed in
their religion and just because they're
not female prophets
do we see females as any less should
they be um female imams leading
men leading men no living man no but
is it because inferior no of course not
look there are things that women are
entitled to that man
we don't have a second wave feministic
paradigm and and for those who want to
know
what the difference is between the
islamic paradigm and the second wave
feministic paradigm
there are many um lectures that i've
done on this the fundamental flaws of
feminism yeah
uh islam the dark phase of feminism just
put these titles in the
descript in the uh search bar you'll
find my my
lectures there it's a paradigmatic
problem in the sense that
you're now imposing a paradigm on
something else this is another problem
right
obviously here uh in terms there's two
different things that are going on at
the same time number one
female scholars are what are being
discussed here yes
so this this female imam thing is a red
herring yes
would you respect someone praying and
bending because
our prayer has all kinds of positioning
a woman bending over in front of man and
kneeling over and it's seen as
inappropriate from our perspective
because of physiological anatomical
differences
and we think and we have good evidence
that that could
uh disturb somebody okay especially a
man
physiologically if they're praying and
what's the evidence of that look you've
got all female schools and all
male schools in your country why don't
you go and question something go to your
country
why don't you go and question a head
teacher of an all-female school and say
why is it that you allow such uh
discrimination to exist
the reason why they don't uh comment on
that is because they've allowed it as
part of the culture even though
really and truly it's something which
opposes them many ways second wave
feministic discourses
so the reasoning behind it if you ask
those who advocate for it
is distraction physiological
psychological distraction
so a woman or girls in a school together
they'll be less distracted if boys were
there and vice versa
for a man's you know the one the way a
man is created yeah the recently i came
across something on youtube yeah there's
something called schwartz yeah
and he was talking about do you know
this female woman
um hostesses in the airplane yeah
they're closing the door so i thought
like closing the what's like i thought
it's something you know there's
interesting videos there maybe is there
a weather closing door
okay i watch the video then like they
won't dress in a property i wish they
were in a skirt
but then i went to the comments
i didn't notice the door exactly get the
hell out of here no no no no no
they know it women yeah they know it
they they know it and so
this uh equality from an islamic
perspective and there is
we have our own version of equality it's
not identicality
exactly it's not identicality it doesn't
mean that men and women have the same
roles and responsibilities in
all cases and there are for example war
like it's not mandated upon women at the
end of the day and this is a very if you
think about the
the reality of war war is the case of
men okay for the most part in history
not just uh in
islamic history but cross-culturally
yeah going out yeah
and sacrificing their lives or
potentially sacrificing their lives
the point of the matter is someone goes
extremely safe for women
this is this is where second word
feminism kind of breaks down because you
start thinking about why don't you
campaign for the draft
for women to to now be compensated in
similar ways that men have been done
at home you go and keep you going get
your limbs chopped off i can come and
say
why am i going to walk why not exactly
there's lots of things right but
if we fail to identify differences
between men and women
then there's going to be all kinds of
absurdities that one can propose from a
feminist perspective
i can say well there's been there's been
200 years
of men being drafted into wars we need
to we need to
out undo this imbalance yes now we have
to draft women
for the next 11 wars for like 12 wars so
that we can undo the just injustice
the point is once again the islamic
understanding of equality does not mean
identicality so
there's a different paradigm and if you
want to be a sophisticated interlocutor
instead of cross-examining somebody on
your world view and your paradigm
try and understand where they're coming
look i don't know if this woman is an
enemy of islam i don't think
i don't think so i think she's just
trying to do her job really i i do think
because it's part of the journalistic
capacity to try and interrogate well you
have to remember something
you do have to remember something that
when you're speaking to my for let's not
talk about our paradigm let me speak to
the woman for a second
let's talk about your paradigm because
you're a journalist yes
you're a journalist who probably is a
liberal with a small l and is trying to
do the work of journalists but the truth
of the matter is
on your paradigm which i'm guessing is a
liberal feminist paradigm
by your questioning you need to make
sure you need to ensure
that you're protecting the rights of the
minorities and you're not it's because
there's something called tyranny of the
majority
tyranny of the majority is something
which is the the dominant
kind of people verbally otherwise the
minority
and they're tyrannizing them okay so
it's
what needs to be done for me anyways if
i was a liberal if i was in your
paradigm
i'd be trying to amplify the voices of
the minorities
so it can kind of create equilibrium for
what would otherwise be a tyranny of the
majority
which is a liberal principle so it
doesn't seem any it doesn't make sense
for me to
for you to bring a minority someone
who's representing a minority group
or actually a double minority because a
woman leader like you know that there's
not that many of them
yeah generally and only that in the
women's hour yeah
honestly yeah yeah you're getting
another woman it doesn't it doesn't make
sense
one second yeah a feminist yeah women's
hour
bbc liberal you're a woman and you're
getting a woman and degrading and
humiliating her
and you are you are a feminist get the
hell out of here yeah you actually
humiliated them
to an achievement that she's done in
your eyes okay she's become the leader
of the muslim council of britain yeah
yeah
instead of upholding and saying you know
you've done a great achievement what you
have to do
you immediately you embarrassed her you
made the feel like she should never
speak to you you should be ashamed of
yourself yeah so
you basically punished her for being a
woman yes if you think about it
so now now other muslim women go look at
that and think well if just
if this is the entitlement of being a
muslim spokesperson then maybe it's not
something i want to be and allah says
that in the quran what does allah say in
the quran what is allah in the quran
they will never be pleased with you
khalas
never so don't feel the sister feel bad
for the sister because she's thinking
okay how can i
fix this one lie very simple for me
there isn't there isn't our religion
says
what yeah yeah now let's go back to one
point here again
well i want to maybe finish with this
the reason why i found that
the the the line of questioning was
unproductive
not just from the islamic perspective
yeah because we said we've got some
issues that we need to
like let's be honest let's be honest
there are there are messages there are
mosques in this country which don't have
access for women
it's unbelievable i told you and the
prophet said let him
do not do not stop the woman slaves of
allah meaning the woman worshipers
going to the mosques of god how can you
how can you facilitate that
how can you facilitate that when there's
not even a space for them to break
up boycotted is very some cause of this
yeah and the thing is look me i went to
one masjid when i told you yeah and they
said
the uncle didn't let the sister come in
this space while i had to go and do
jamal with a sister outside because it
was the nightclubs
yeah so there are problems there are
problems and we see that and that's
within our own paradigms
access access is limited we need to we
need to help we need to work within our
own paradigm to allow women just like
just like in the medieval period and
just like in the in the time of the
prophet
yeah where access was was was there
right
and as a result women were edified and
they were edifiers
we need to bring that back and there's
no there's no other and we have that
within our own paradigm but it's
unproductive
okay it's unproductive for a woman who
is probably a liberal probably a
feminist
to go down this line of
questioning bullying which was number
one alienate
muslim spokespeople number two show
other women that this is
the intelligent of being a spokesperson
thereby
you know acting as a barrier to entrance
to such a thing
if you're if you're trying to promote
women being in power positions so-called
power positions from your liberal
paradigm
if you're trying to promote that this is
a very bad way of doing so
you should be you should be offering
support and so on so i think from our
paradigm and your paradigm
you've not achieved anything and quite
frankly it shows uh theological
incompetence and illiteracy that you
couldn't even know the difference
between an imam and a priest and a rabbi
and imam is nowhere
yes sometimes imams have pastoral
responsibilities
sometimes they can have that but it's
not that's not a necessary part of their
job sometimes they just go and lead the
prayer
this is this is literally the job
description leading the prayer some
children do this
it's not equivalent and so the question
should have been how many
muslim authorities do you have sheikhs
or sheikha's in this case
or mufti's or so on and compare that
with the rabbi and
if you do that by the way yeah if you do
that across time i will sh i will
promise you i'll bet my bottom dollar
that if you do it from the time of the
prophet
to this time no i'm not talking about
21st century uk
let's let's do a longitudinal study of
of the entire time period there's no way
i'm sorry
there is absolutely no way that you ha
that in the christian tradition and the
jewish tradition there's even i would
even go as far as say one tenth
yes and i'm making this claim yeah one
tenth as much representation
yeah maybe even that if i'm telling you
there's a book with ten
thousand names of by of just one
subfield of islamic studies
you can't even go there you can't even
go there with this we have we have uh
sahabi at that literally preserve the
tradition so
it's the case is closed you didn't know
how to question you didn't know the
implications of the question and you
didn't know what to question
but this is a lesson for all of us that
before you have these interviews on bbc
quite frankly you need to be ready for
that kind of confrontation number one
and number two you know get ready for
the muslim retaliation because we we
shouldn't
we should not allow the media bullies to
to do this to us
yeah we need to have our voices as well
and our sisters and look social media
our outlets like your channel my channel
and
our channels and so on this is becoming
now
a big way of retaliating yeah which is
why you need to subscribe to this
channel and like and share the video
thank you
for my channel oh my god by the way
yeah inshallah bryan sisters it's very
important the reason we did is because
we saw our sister being bullied and i'll
be honest with you i feel like she's
been bullied so share this video with
what's your name emma barrett wherever
nick barnett whoever her name is yeah
okay send this to her okay she needs to
watch this and
re um focus her evaluation re-evaluate
her everything that she's doing yeah she
needs to re-evaluate
because she's totally well she's just
bullied that sister that's a feminist
unbelievable we are so promises please
share that with them uh with the
uh emma inshallah and hopefully she can
fix the ways bbc get this video down and
show this absolute humiliation
embarrassment to your uh standards
whatever you guys are doing until next
time to the snap of the guardians
goodbye